hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report
i may have to start wearing even wider
ties
since we're going back to the 1970s
possibly even
a leisure suit powder blue
of course stacy right i know i actually
thought of wearing my poncho for this
episode because you know how that how
flower child thing was happening in the
70s and of course
you and i remember the 70s during the
oil embargo and then the iranian
revolution
which caused price spikes in gasoline
and shortages here across america and we
have them again max and i drove
from northern virginia down to north
carolina so
about a 325 mile drive and
as we're heading further and further
south there are more and more gas
stations without
any gas and those that did have gasoline
had
huge lines sometimes miles long so
it was um so weird in this time of
pandemic
and shortages and loads of things like
microchips and
other well in the beginning of the
pandemic of course we had food shortages
now we also have oversupply and like uh
you know money and treasuries and bonds
all over the place that's why we have
negative yielding buttons and stuff like
that so we have all sorts of price
signals
messed up and crazy times oh right the
crisis ends and the crisis begins that's
the way it used to be
now there is just one crisis on top of
another you don't know where
one starts and one stops and it's just a
multiple crises stacked up
you know right there in front of you and
you're thinking to yourself my goodness
gracious
what happened and you know when i was
looking at all these lines at the
gas stations that did have any gasoline
available i was thinking
you know in the 1970s at least like we
had jobs to go to like people were
working and
had to work for their money we had
stagflation just like we have now
but back then like there were no
um this there was very little welfare
available
and in fact remember when new york city
went broke
what did ford say to new york city
dropped dead
said go go broke now nobody's allowed to
go broke so
there's all this money of course also
there are anti-gouging laws
so even though people were showing up
with canisters all over the place
filling up tanks huge tanks filled with
gasoline
the price signal was saying do it like
go for it it's cheap because you're
about to have
total shortage right so this price
signal
is an important uh fact to wrap our
minds around and how do empires collapse
how do countries collapse
and we saw a fantastic collapse in uh
with the soviet union and they had a
similar situation where it wasn't about
the price signal of money failing it was
about the price signal of
manufacturing failing in other words
they were
keen on putting out a certain number of
farm equipment and tractors no matter
what the cost they had no accounting for
it they just wanted this raw number of
farm equipment and that was a metric
that they use like we oh we
we generated x number of a hundred
thousand tractors
and there's no price signals so it
collapsed
here in the united states the money
itself is not uh
driven by any kind of a price signal
it's uh it's
the polar bureau called the federal open
market committee
and they stay fixed prices or they rig
prices or they
uh control prices price control for
the dollar and so all price signals like
in the soviet union
have gone nuts and similarly like the
soviet union
the united states is now collapsing of
course
we're comparing it to the 1970s when we
also had shortages
due to uh conflict happening in the
middle east we're
we're having conflict now but that
doesn't impact anything and these price
signals
back in the 1970s we saw um huge
inflation
but we also saw interest rates soaring
right
so zero hedge points out that the last
time core cpi was here the fed funds
rate was 20
you know the core cpi numbers came in
and it's over four percent but they're
like if you exclude food and energy
it's only three percent um of course
there is that
base problem where like it's comparing
it to last year during the middle of the
beginning of the pandemic so they're
saying that's why it's higher than it is
but again because they distort price
signals
and the price signal at the gasoline
station for example is telling you that
there's no problem
no shortages plenty of supply
two dollars and eighty-five cents is
only up like three three four cents
since the the knockout of the pipeline
happened
and that whole disintegration we've been
talking about the disintegration
and the deglobalization and the entropy
that happens
in a system like the us dollar which
turns 50 this year or the u.s empire
which maybe turns 65.70 this year
and what you're seeing is like with this
uh
the pipeline being taken out i mean it's
hard to get real information about it
but
what it seems like is like people are
saying this shouldn't be able to happen
like that the the fact that one pipeline
provides 45
of the gasoline to the entire east coast
of america
but that they could be taken offline by
uh some sort of hack or pressing an
email the
wrong link or something right well
having a lack of diversity and
competition in the oil business as the
result
of mergers and acquisitions and the
monopolization or oligopolization of the
u.s economy thanks to cheap money and
private equity
and no regulators and no respect of
competition or free market enterprise
now going back to the 1970s yes interest
rates went up to 20 percent
and the bond market crashed because
the price signal told the central bank
at the time under paul volcker
that thanks to richard nixon's money
printing and default on the us dollar in
the 1970s and the problems associated
with the cost of the vietnam war
that had to be wrong out of the system
there was too much fiat money
had to be rung out of the system so at
that time in the 70s
america was not scared and hiding under
the bed about the fact that they would
have to actually work for a living
and be productive in some way uh unlike
today
where people are not working they
they're they fear the
work has become a four letter word in
america
well again it's the price signal because
as we've covered and many in the media
have been covering the fact that
you know with government transfers that
have you know if you're staying at home
and not working out
and on enhanced unemployment benefits
you're making over 16
an hour and that is a problem we saw
that on this drive
up to north virginia and back is we saw
help
wanted signs everywhere literally
everywhere even in
abandoned like fields of of where used
to be
agricultural agricultural fields along
the rivers you know
you saw signs like delivery driver
needed urgent
and that brings me to the other problem
with what is happening with the gasoline
is that apparently there's also a cnn
was already warning for example
before this pipeline shut down and that
was that there would be
shortages of gasoline at gas stations
because there's a huge
shortage of delivery drivers because
there's a very specialized
field that you to be able to drive you
know a tanker filled with fuel
so there are there the shut the pandemic
shut down the schools that trained the
younger ones coming online
but there's also new regulations that
were brought in in january 2020
whereby if you've had any sort of drug
or
alcohol related conviction you're not
allowed to drive so that
kicked off between 40 and 60 000 people
that wanted to be
delivery drivers but they can't be
because of these uh past records
so there is um this it's a general
entropy and
disintegration right it's like
everything it's not one thing goes wrong
everything goes wrong right well the
problem with billionaires
is not that they uh by some
don't pay enough taxes the problem is
that they got to be billionaires by
hollowing out the economy yeah by
destroying the infrastructure
by stealing from pension accounts from
destroying the moral fabric of the
country
people like warren buffett or jeff bezos
or bill gates et cetera et cetera they
did so
they achieved their wealth at the
expense of the common good they
literally threw the country under the
bus
and now we're dealing with the
consequences of really it started with
reagan and thatcher and the deregulation
and the
central banks became activists under
greenspan bernanke yellen and now jay
powell
where they do the bidding of the
oligarchs and america has a very nasty
oligarch problem
and we need a leader that can deal with
the oligarchs clearly the current
policy leadership in the washington has
no way to deal with oligarchy in america
that's sad
so going back to the 1970s and comparing
the situation to then
uh we're 50 years since the u.s dollar
began in a global reserve
fiat standard in 1971 when nixon took us
off the gold window
so full circle like we started this year
saying the us dollar
turns 50 is it going to make this year
and of course the entropy sets in
the entropy sets in and the human being
when you turn 50s
things start going wrong you know it
takes you longer to recover
from certain things the same thing i
believe is happening
and you can see this and again another
zero hedge headline and that is rabobank
richard nixon was the last u.s president
to face a major economic crisis
involving soaring inflation and gasoline
and supply chains
and the middle east and the superpower
rivalry and the u.s dollar itself
so you're starting to see all that that
the cycle
turn the fourth turning all the stuff
the entropy is setting in the
disintegration is happening and i might
say like
again on the drive you know you could do
it yourself anybody could go
do the drive if you could find some
gasoline and what you'll see
is uh bizarrely which i had not been
expecting is the trump 2024
bumper stickers and yard signs all over
the place i was a little bit surprised
to see that because i hadn't really read
about it you know the 70s
also featured um disco
and um a an abandonment of the rock and
roll era
which was a net benefit i think to some
degree because we had they
had to endure what's called progressive
rock
and we fortunately came to
the church of iggy pop who
punked us out of the nixon
malays so we need a new iggy pop or
bring back iggy pop i just saw him on
youtube with a parrot
singing some song that's what we need we
need to get packed
pop back well we have better than iggy
pop we have bitcoin and that's in the
news because we've also been covering
stan druckenmiller who's been pretty
active
warning about this like he started back
at the end of the summer when all the
money printing was becoming quite
apparent
and he was expressing his concern and it
was telling everybody and we told you
that he was saying that he's very very
very short the u.s
dollar and he's even further short the
u.s dollar
here she was on cnbc this week and he
said that he doesn't think the us dollar
as a reserve currency will survive for
another 15 years
so again that sounding like us he's one
of the most legendary of hedge fund
managers in the world
was part of the soros quantum fund when
they shorted the
pound and forced them out of the
exchange rate mechanism he also said
stan rockford miller five years ago i
said crypto was a solution
in search of a problem well now the
problem has been clearly identified is
jerome powell and the rest of the
world's central bankers
there's a lack of trust but you can
trust kai's report we've been telling
you
all this time like he didn't see it five
years ago we told you five years ago now
he's saying yes stacey and max are right
five years ago this is this is causing
all the money printing is causing for 10
years
and we said the problem with central
banks yes we did for 10 years
yes so stan druckenmiller is like oh
finally i figured it out
you know had you been doing what we have
been doing stan your performance would
have been
a thousand times better you wouldn't be
losing money like ray dalio
so back in the 70s when we were talking
about when this all began
then we had paul volcker who who is the
one that took
interest rates up to 80 make iggy pop
head of the central bank
he's the new pole vault okay he could be
the new paul bulker look bitcoin is the
solution for all problems
i see there's a lot of kerfuffle in the
mideast again
you know everyone was on a bitcoin
standard peace and love would break out
and we could finally get over this
craziness but you know everyone will
learn in their own time and they'll pay
what they deserve for bitcoin
going to take a break and when we come
back much more coming your way
back to the kaiser report i'm max kaiser
time now to go to a very special guest
the inimitable david morgan of the
morgan report
david welcome back back's been a little
too long thanks for having me back
right i'm i'm just figuring out which
one of us
is getting more gray hair i think you
might be winning that race
but i'm a close second now let's move on
david i got to ask you are you having
flashbacks of the 1970s
uh gasoline shortages everybody
unemployed
uh what next very much so
it does remind me of the oil crunch i
lived through it i was pretty young in
those days
and yeah you filled up based on your
license plate if it ended with an even
or an odd number
a lot of tension in the air a lot of
uncertainty
and we're back at the same place only
it's on a global scale
i know it's just u.s based primarily but
it's worldwide
based on a lot of things primarily the
reserve currency being the dollar and of
course
it's been offed quite a bit with what's
going on in the crypto world that you're
much more familiar with than me
and the uh people that refused to use
the dollar in international commerce you
know
circumvented the swiss system so lots of
things playing out this time
that didn't exist the last time we faced
this kind of a crisis
yeah exactly uh lots of things that were
not present back then
are going to be adding to the dimension
of this particular period as you point
out
the us dollar of course world reserve
currency and that seems to be spreading
this 1970s like
stagflation and everything associated
with it to a global basis
we're at a 50-year anniversary of the
dollar uh people like stan druckenmiller
and others don't think the dollar is
even going to get to august
and even get to the 50-year anniversary
um and um you know this is all coming
together
in a kind of uh a convergence of
of disaster and um
you know you do mention the us dollar
there
and there is a global rejection
seemingly of the us dollar
and there's a lot of pieces to that
puzzle how do you approach that
well you know it's probably been
overstated max but i approach it based
on the debt bomb
you know it's all confidence it's
complete con game
if you don't trust a dollar you know six
months out why would you buy a 30-year
treasury
so it's this back and forth yield curve
yield adjustment
the way that they can financialize
everything and make people continue to
play the bond market basically on a
trading vehicle basis rather than on an
investment basis
it's starting to wear thin as you well
know and i think we don't have a lot
longer i certainly wouldn't put myself
in the same category as stan
drunkenmiller but i would say
august seems a little early i certainly
wouldn't rule it out but we're seeing
the last message of hope
with the central bankers to push this
fiat currency any further and that's why
you see the competing currency meme so
strong with bitcoin and the other
cryptos
people are looking for a way out very
typical the end of a fiat experiment
yeah it's kind of sad because you myself
and others have been talking about
some things like how the u.s economy has
gotten hollowed out zero percent
interest rates remember
back in the 70s it was illegal for
companies to do
stock buybacks for obvious reasons it's
rank stock manipulation and yet starting
in the 80s
starting with reagan and the
deregulation that became legal
and companies don't manufacture anymore
they don't hire
decent wages anymore use they buy back
their own stock to manipulate their own
stocks so that the executives can
make hundreds of billions of dollars and
uh
so the economy in the country if you
look at the infrastructure fails the
roads and bridges are failing the
gas is unavailable it's it's
it's been hollowed out i mean i i don't
i don't think it's too
too far of a stretch to say we're
entering
a similar moment as the soviet union did
when it collapsed i think it's for the
similar reasons it's just the economy is
much too fragile
the the leadership is essentially an
oligarchy at this point there's no
democratic rule
of of raw of law is that too far of a
stretch
no it sounds very do me gloomy but i
have to say i think you're doing a
reasoned uh
response to the real situation and the
only thing i could add further
max and you did a great job is
glass-steagall i mean if we had that
intact where commercial banks
lent to farmers and builders uh
you know built out infrastructure and
you didn't have to play russian roulette
with the
investment markets we might have a
stronger economy but once under the
clinton administration i'm bipartisan i
hate all politicians equally
but i think that uh you know we'd have a
different economy but once
everyone started playing this uh
investment banking game whether they
wanted to or not it distorted
the misallocation of capital that we
talked about in the movie we're in
together
so many years ago and it's continued to
go down that trail and i think we're
getting out of road i think you know
kicking the count down the road i think
we hit the end
right of course at the end of the 1970s
at the end of it and stagflationary
period
paul volcker uh jack rates
up the bond market collapsed and that
was probably the last time he had true
price discovery in a major market in
america
because starting in the 1980s and
particularly after the crash of 87 where
greenspan robert rubin and reagan
interceded and started to buy stocks for
their
the house account in washington dc you
haven't had price discovery it's been
price fixing
it's been the price of money itself or
interest rates is a pull-up bureau
of bureaucrats in washington that
establishes those rates
and now 50 you know 40 years later it's
predictably
a predictable collapse because we
haven't had free market capitalism in 35
40 years in america it's been an
oligarchy and the oligarchy's
these billionaires they didn't do it
because they're smart they did it
because they stole it
you know warren buffett's got to be
probably
the the guy who's transferred more
wealth
to him personally but using
accounting fraud and market manipulation
than anyone in history
right he's never invented anything he's
never done anything productive
he's only been on the receiving end of
major oligarchic fraud in america
and and now it's the chickens are coming
home to roost and he'll be gone him and
charlie will be in the
they'll they'll be gone soon and what
did they leave behind
but it's an enormous garbage of a mess
it's disgusting
i love your guts and your honesty and
your straightforwardness max i always
have and
i really can't add on to it except that
to say you know we've got to have the
right attitude we have to accept
those facts you just outlined and
understand with consequences of that
you know there's a there's a law you
know it's a
law of you have to read the uh the
repercussions of what you've sown we've
shown bad seed for a long time
we faked it we phonied it we are under
an oligarch control and now we're going
to have to pay the price on a societal
basis
and the more you are able to understand
that
the better you're able to cope because
at this point there's really no way out
people have asked you well what are we
doing i say you got to wait for it to
bottom
i think we're not going to be steep down
the hill
you know crash to the you know bottom
but you know that possibility exists i
don't want to be too gloomy here max but
the point being what's going on there
you know north carolina where you are
with this pipeline situation these
these complex societies have problems
that compound
you know when the oil doesn't flow then
the transportation isn't the same and
then people start hoarding
then you get more fear in the system and
then they start thinking well maybe
what's the next thing to be short of and
these things have a way of let's say
exploding exponentially before you know
it
yeah you know i'm watching the fed here
under jay powell
and um they've increased the money
supply in the last year or so
in terms of the entire history of money
supply in america they've increased it
by 25
or so just in the last year so it it
i got to believe that they know kind of
what they're doing it's like one of
those
teen movies where the teenagers find the
the parents liquor you know cabinet and
they decide to go crazy for the weekend
they know they're going to get in
trouble but they do it anyway
so i think the fed knows that these are
the
the last days of disco that the party is
over
and jay powell is just like before
collapses i'm just going to do one last
super multi-100 billion dollar injection
to my friends
am i being cynical or is he or is he
simply just
before he retires and starts working for
jeff bezos or starts working for one of
these guys
or citadel capital where of course uh
ben bernanke is
and and he he oversaw the game stop
fiasco
if not engineered it right is it is he
just doing a one last push to get that
big
big big job once he once he leaves the
fed the central bank
uh david i guess the most truthful
answer i can give you max is i don't
know but i certainly agree with your
metaphor your analogy i think it's
extremely accurate
there is no exact point with most
mainstream economists what's
hyperinflation
most of us give it a rule of thumb of
about 20 percent
when you've increased the money supply
25 as you so eloquently said we know
we are in dire straits we know we're at
the end of the game
and yet they'll have the let's say
guts to get on national itv and say if
inflation starts the career it's equally
ugly ahead
we have the tools to put it back in a
box which is ludicrous there's
absolutely no way so
i'm looking for a stagflationary
depression
uh some things will be going up like
everything we need
like food and energy housing and
everything we don't need like the third
big screen tv that's you know 100 inches
by
200 or whatever this nonsense goes with
the
you know iphone 27.2 a lot of that
stuff's
not it's going to be here but a lot of
stuff that we don't necessarily need to
survive
probably will come down in price which
you could say is deflationary but the
stuff we really need to live
it's going to continue to go higher
right so david
for you know long time we've been told
inflation's 1.6 percent just got some
data
now they're saying oh oh it's 4.6 that
still seems
way understated david morgan well i've
been adherent to
john williams and i try to seek truth in
all aspects of my life and
john calculates the inflation rates
based on how the calculation was done in
1980.
if you use those metrics and you use
food and energy the two things people
need the most you have about a 9.7
percent inflation rate right now
if i could be so bold to move on a
little bit further i just answered this
question for one of my members he said
well
i'm worried about this inflation thing
and i know it's good for the medals but
then higher interest rates push the gold
price down
i said it's pretty simple to answer you
have to look at what is the true
inflation rate and what's
the interest rate and look at those
terms so what i'm saying is
you have nothing to fear with an
interest rate to about nine percent
because that's the true inflation rate
when volcker came in
interest rates by the cpi which was
accurate in 1980 was 13
he pushed interest rates up to 20
percent which gave you a delta of 7
real yield that killed the gold market
helped the bond crush the bond market
but put the country back on track and
the best investment you could make for
the last 40 years
was the long bond those days are over
and the point i'm making and you can
reemphasize
max is they can't do that again we don't
have the margin to do it you put
interest rates up to probably
four or five percent the interest that's
owed on the national debt would be so
astronomical you couldn't even make the
interest payments all right we're going
to have to cut it there
carry it over to the second segment
david thanks for being on kaiser report
my pleasure thank you and that's going
to do it for this edition of kaiser
report with me max kaiser and stacy
herbert want to thank our guest david
morgan of the morgan report
until next time bye y'all
[Music]